Rosina Tokyo Karim optimal master  phenomenal de goiânia okay but I'm not  going nationalist ammonia what I see  some toys alcohol  we should eat unlike I don't mind us  Godzilla king of the monsters alive  searching up from the depths of the sea  on a tidal wave of Terror a gigantic  Beast  [Music]  is this man  civilization in 1954 we awaken something  this island is just the beginning  in the Pacific yes there are  of years these creatures have remained  in hiding around the world  [Music]  Eudora  how many these things are there 17  uncountable  she's easily we listed our handsome man  is thinking nature is in our control and  not the other way around  black thing for Donna  have no idea what's coming  because it was one  [Music]